sure you can't explain the magic trick
everyone's gonna be like
okay i hate it so you pulled a frog out
of his mouth what made you think it was
a good idea to say that
you know what let me tell you
let me tell you once you stop laughing
uncontrollably
oh [ __ ] okay you want to know how i have
adult adv
it's because i literally i literally was
like i really wasn't
explaining in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast we have a nick the pink
shirt and eye ear and we also have
patrick dot t-dot riley
with all the extra dots
and not some some handle yeah you
[ __ ] because it they don't have it
somebody has my [ __ ] name dude
somebody has patrick t riley what's your
middle name thomas
thomas
riley my cousins used to call me
tomatoes when i was little and i used to
cry so hard
but i still got called way worse than
that yeah like a mother
things that you can't say in this day
and you'll be like yeah she's wrong
idiot piece of [ __ ] once you read a book
you idiot hooked up phonics you sunk
you suck cat [ __ ] idiot
you can tell he's hurting on the inside
i know that's a painful laugh he's
hurting a little bit were you really on
phonics though as a kid yeah i was
hooked on my phone
bro almost i think in all i think
naturally i'm just a very late bloomer i
think i just
was late to the party wait let me ask
you something
because i actually don't know what is
hooked on phonics and then how do you
get out of hooked on phonics i
don't remember in a [ __ ] casket brush
yes
you don't even know how do you get it
just gotta get out hey shout out to all
the hooked up phonics hands out there
who can't speak english or what okay so
there used to be these like
remember you don't remember okay so it's
like remember the now cds like was like
now cds and they would sell now cds
so like it was like an infomercial like
that but
it was hooked on phonics so it like if
you had trouble reading or something it
was like a program designed to like help
you read
phonetically or whatever some [ __ ] like
that it was like dvds i sent your house
and it was like hooked on phonics it was
really catchy little jingle
and it was this whole thing but i don't
know i've never met did you use it for
real
no i did use it i've never second grade
bro like i was your boy had struggles
reading
you're the only dude i ever met actually
used that thing damn for i thought it
was very
my parents made it seem like it was very
popular look like i was very slow in
everything bro like
it took me a while and it makes sense
right like for me
it took it took me a while to like get
things you know what i mean you know
what's crazy
i wasn't born here and i wasn't hooked
on phonics
you're [ __ ] dumb this is what it is
it's like i just wanted to call you
stupid
oh my [ __ ] oh god yeah you know
korean and i was never hooked on phones
yeah whatever bro korean like they're
just a different type of being okay
yeah how my parents explained and taught
me things
was a lot of yelling a lot of screaming
and like i didn't get things very well
like math bro my dad would make me in
the summer time
he would make me fill out like like uh
math workbooks
and he wouldn't teach me how to do it
like i just was like just do it that's
just poor parenting
yeah like my sisters would try to help
me you know but like
everybody will get really frustrated
with me so like i remember like the
hooked on phonics i was really bad at
like i just couldn't
it was really hard for me and i think a
lot of it was i was like scared because
they would like yell at me all the time
like whenever my parents or my family
would explain things to me like i would
just like
i don't know but like my uncle he would
help i remember him
when he taught me when he would do the
[ __ ] on phonics stuff with me
you can't even [ __ ] say it dude can
you read
the conor mcgregor the [ __ ] up
but i remember like he was really
patient with me and i was like oh i
remember like
feeling success when i would do with him
but your boy's a slow learner
and well how would your uncle teach you
though he just wouldn't yell at me
and like i remember i couldn't ride a
bike for a while i just couldn't like i
was on training wheels until i was like
11 we talked about this until 11.
until i was like 11 bro cause i remember
on my 11th birthday my grandma got me a
scooter
a razor dog you [ __ ] lose dog
i would have never been friends with you
[Laughter]
i avoided you dude like the plague like
[ __ ] this
hey guys you're that kid that [ __ ]
waves with his whole arm
it's over here me just wave with your
hands nick no
i know you're joking but it's still
hurtful
uh and then like uh so
that's what taught me how to balance and
then ride a bike
and then and then as soon as i got on
the bike i was like oh this is easy bro
like
and i'm waiting wheels and i'm too big
for my bike because i'm 11. you know
yeah damn until 11 yeah training wheels
when none of your friends were like yo
what the [ __ ] are with these things like
take them off
what do you mean like friends
oh like my grandma yeah she's in my
backyard she's just roasting your ass
yeah you [ __ ] she was gonna thought
you [ __ ] [ __ ] like she's
like look at me i'm nick
oh you're gonna cry you should do that
live [ __ ] punch your chest
look at my father
yeah if they were gonna be abusive and
yell at me they might as well have gone
the full mile
right they didn't do all that they just
like yeah [ __ ] it whatever and then
they'd figure it out they just gave up
on you yeah i just gave them oh that's
sad
because my sisters they were like they
were good like they picked [ __ ] up quick
you know
oh and then i was like they're like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with this dude bro
like
[ __ ] idiot i didn't even make math
field day in my fourth grade year what
is that math field day math field day is
like a thing that kids do
what is that like it's like a math
competition all the smart kids do that
[ __ ]
my sister both my sisters did it and
then
my turn didn't ask they're like you was
really [ __ ] up and i will always
remember this from my uh third grade
class right
so they would do they teach
multiplications in third grade or second
grade i forgot which one i think third
third third right so it was third grade
i'm right four for me because i'm slow
so in third grade we would go up the
multiplication table right
and so what the teacher would do on
every friday it would be like an ice
cream sundae party
but your toppings that you would have
will be based on how much you can go up
to multiplication
oh no so your boy the fattest kid in
class that only got vanilla ice cream
yeah you can't even do one you go you
hey man hey hold on
he was like i could do one and ten i
think
times ten your boys was like a lot of
times when you do it all the way through
to like 10
and then yeah and that would just get
you like a spoon yeah
you can walk in the room so i would just
only have vanilla ice cream you see all
the other kids with like [ __ ]
strawberries whipped cream and chocolate
it was a terrible way to teach kids [ __ ]
because it would make me feel ashamed
yeah so i would just have my vanilla
sometimes i just have a bowl
i'm just over here just eating air like
peter peter pan yeah
this ice cream is so good you wish you
guys had my stuff
clinking it clean clink it it clean
click it
oh yeah it's just an empty bowl
dude it's so fast you guys couldn't even
see it
oh my god i'm pretty sure now with like
the the curriculum and what they know
they would never let a teacher do that
yeah probably not you know that's
[ __ ] terrible that's old school they
should bring that
that's old school yeah but i got her
back when i stabbed that kid in the face
in front of her she was screaming yeah
[ __ ] bloody murder yeah you scarred
her
that's what you get for not giving me
ice cream [ __ ] i know 10 times 10
though
[ __ ] i still remember her [ __ ] scream
she was mortified i just remembered i
just you know just bro imagine you were
a teacher what grade are you in third
grade third grade
imagine you're in you're a third grade
teacher and one of your students
this little handsome korean boy stabs
another gentleman in the cheek i'd be
like oh [ __ ] with a pen
oh [ __ ] she got real a world star hard
work
oh get his
and then she started rolling out on that
[ __ ] white
metal and little tin [ __ ] paper towel
the recycled paper towel
oh my god yeah she started balling it up
and putting on his cheek because it was
bleeding and stuff
and she was screaming what did you do
and i was like i just pitched it i sword
of god
that was my excuse did they pull the
stick they pulled the pencil out no i i
didn't know i
i i stabbed him because i was writing
some [ __ ] and i just started hammer
fisting him in the face
and so the one that that contacted him
was it was
went through his cheek but it stayed in
there the pencil or i pulled it out
oh you pulled it up and then when i
pulled it out i was like i was like
oh [ __ ] and you just see him go hold his
face
and he starts crying and i'm like what
happened so you think it hurt
huh i think i didn't know why he stopped
and he was bleeding because i couldn't
register what was going on and i just
looked at my hand and there was the
murder weapon yo that that's how people
get hurt oh that is what happens that's
literally what dropped out you get
murked like you just black out and
you're like oh [ __ ] there's a dead body
almost in my defense and i've said this
before on the podcast he hit me first
so you know what don't play with fire
unless you're trying to get arsoned
i think that's how the saying goes i
think so well now it is like
a new one damn dude that's pretty crazy
[ __ ] deserved
[ __ ] degenerate dude that was
happening this is porky in the face
but i already got suspended twice before
that so that was the last
strikes that was like literally the last
straw because before that i got it i got
this kid whose name was brian i think
his name was brian grant like the
basketball player
but his mom used to go to my parents
store all the time but this dude
um he did oh i know what he did he
[ __ ] stalked me in my stomach
yeah and so but that led us to [ __ ] a
scrapping sure and then we both got in
trouble
and then his mom brought him over to
our store to apologize to me at the
store oh nice yeah i was like ty yeah
your mom needs a discount at our store
[ __ ]
she's trying to keep that discount i
used to get uh bullied by a kid named
lorraine
now the fun game is going to be all
right let's be finished let me finish
you don't need to finish no no listen
listen
the fun game is was this uh person
lorraine was it a boy or a girl
it was a girl boy okay his name is
lorraine and he broke my bruce lee
[ __ ] metal lunch box right
wow i wasn't i think i was in like third
grade fourth grade or something like
that i didn't mention hate and i didn't
even know i was being bullied bro like i
didn't even know i was being bullied
and this kid lorraine my mom would like
try to slander his name and she would
say like he throws rocks at people
uh at cars over highway overpasses like
that's
just spreading rumors yeah
i think that that's what he was like i
think he did he was doing so my mom was
just like telling other parents like see
you know this [ __ ] was bullying
me and [ __ ] but like lorraine plays with
his penis in front of all the women
yeah was he french and [ __ ] lorraine bro
this kid was hood as [ __ ] he was super
lorraine really ran like a franchise
name i don't know bro so is that a
girl's name lorraine it is
that's a hella girl yeah and he kind of
looked like a girl like he actually was
mistaken for a girl sometimes
that's why he had very feminine yeah did
you guys fight what happened did you
just
i don't i honestly don't remember like
him you just let him [ __ ] up your
lunchbox
he didn't do anything yeah like i just
was like what the [ __ ] man
and then let me see what's in there for
lunch
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you don't have cheese in here you're
just always smoking a long cigarette
like
the [ __ ] long cigarette and the glove
that goes all over his elbow
what is that bro the little stick that
you put together
what the [ __ ] you're an [ __ ] you're
an [ __ ] actually what could be cool
to smoke
it's a symbol status or something right
it was supposed to be very fantastic
extendo
you got the extender i had a buddy who
used to smoke weed in high school that
like a french [ __ ] like that
he would just take a hit and he'd be
like what like a [ __ ]
like girl what the [ __ ] are you doing
dog you're like a french [ __ ] you're
watching
circle bro yeah yeah you kind of [ __ ]
up the vibe you wetting up the blunt bro
like oh my god that's so weird you know
ever since i went up the blunt bro
do you think people will ever start
[ __ ] sharing blunts like they used to
because of rona now i think eventually
in time
[ __ ] be licking that [ __ ] i was
smoking some joints during them
actually i just saw something you know
what i just saw some dudes uh
the other night sharing some joints like
that yeah didn't give a [ __ ]
this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends i believe that the year
of 2021 is the year that we all focus on
our mental health because we need it now
more than ever
and better help is here to help you get
on track
i have been using better help now for
the past couple of years
and i got matched up to a therapist that
i really really enjoyed
and the great thing is if you guys get
matched up to a therapist that maybe
doesn't match for you you have the
option to switch out and find somebody
that does work for you
on top of that there's financial aid
stuff that'll help people out there who
might be in a financial bind
and even better you can message your
counselor 24 7 and they'll get right
back to you this
is probably one of the most convenient
things i've ever used
specifically when it comes to finding a
therapist or being or talking to a
therapist in general so remember my
friends this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp and
geniusbrainlisteners get 10 off their
first month
at betterhelp.com genius that's once
again betterhelp.com
genius so don't wait on it and get the
mental help
you need for your mental health and
smile more today my friends
but we should get into the subject today
uh people have been just like i was in
hawaii for a week and the whole world is
exploding while i'm gone because
apparently every [ __ ] youtuber out
there is just raping people
like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah man
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of
great professionals right like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with these
you know what it is man i really do
believe these people
are the most socially awkward human
beings that has
that doesn't even know how to navigate
through this world and the moment that
they have some type of power they try to
use it against somebody yeah because
they they've been in the opposite end
where they're the [ __ ] dweeb they
don't have any power and now they're all
[ __ ] power hungry
now that aha just sticking their dick in
[ __ ] everywhere they want like what
the [ __ ]
they act like it's like owed to them or
some [ __ ] yeah they're like well
nothing's going to happen to me i'm a
[ __ ] god
at this point so the first person
first person up to bat
there was a girl she's a tick talker i'm
not going to go look into my phone but
you guys already
you should know she's a she's a famous
tic-tock popular tick-tock right
so she goes on tick-tock or no she goes
on youtube and i saw a little
clip of it on twitter where she talks
about how jake paul and her went to a
party together they were together and
you know
the reason why a lot of people or some
people are discrediting her is because
of the way she speaks she kind of
speaks a little slow she says that they
start making out and he starts putting
moves on her and then she's like no i
don't really want to do this
and he goes okay cool then there's
really no point in us continuing this
like there's no point
and then they go fine so she sits down
and then out of nowhere i [ __ ] you not
she says this is what this guy does
they stop making out they're sitting
down and then he pulls down his pants
and this starts face [ __ ] her oh
no segway sitting down and she he gets
up so she assumes that they're going to
leave the [ __ ] bedroom and this
scumbag
pulls down his pants allegedly because
we don't know we haven't heard her side
of this literally
but this is her story that he pulls down
his [ __ ] pen and just
facebook and then comes in her mouth and
then just
lays her down hugs her and goes let's
get back down to party
wow that's what what the [ __ ]
did rape like a face rape is that that's
face rape [ __ ] up
dude and just her telling the story i
couldn't like wrap my head around what
the [ __ ] happened like
so she goes hey i'm done i i don't i
don't really feel comfortable with this
and then he goes cool well there's no
point in us continuing this
and then he gets it pulls down his
passive face monster you know why
has he responded has he said anything he
hasn't responded he has a match coming
up so it's probably smart for him not to
say something just ignore it you know
you know what's gonna happen though
because
the fight whatever happens even if he
loses or wins
somehow most likely this story is
probably just swept under the rug
just with a bigger story like of him
having this fight
you know that's probably what they're
banking on dude that's so crazy bro
like in my head and when you hear these
stories you're just thinking like
how the [ __ ] if you think of jake paul
right it's like all right
not typically a very likable guy
when you hear him talk right as far as
like his persona
you know what i mean so when you hear
him like can you hear a story about like
dude this guy grabbed a chick the back
of her head started [ __ ] face [ __ ]
her
like even that is kind of like can
i don't want to say hard to believe but
like how do you wrap your head around
this type of story
she lightweight roasted him too she was
like 30 seconds
hey she lightly roasted his ass so she
threw it a little
yeah bro cause that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah that's a unique story he's a
big [ __ ] guy too so if you wanted to
force himself on her she wouldn't be
able to do anything
it was a facebook he did you know the
only thing she could
is just bite that [ __ ] dick off you
should have just [ __ ] have you ever
seen that self-defense video that
was like it's like an 80s self-defense
video have you seen that no it's like
some guy
and like or a girl i don't know who it
is it's a guy and a ghee i feel like i
don't know if i'm get [ __ ] it up
but he has a cucumber he's like when he
grabs you put your head down and then
it's just i think a dude that's doing it
he bites the cucumber
god he's like bite his dick off it's
like crazy
with like pastel purple backgrounds it's
like a legit video
yeah i i it's like a legit self-defense
video it's like 80s it's like what you
would see on big dojo
yeah like those types of videos it's
just like but like some hillbillies
they're all
real too but it's real all those people
on mcdojo they're like oh
this is they're real people they're real
people thinking like this is real [ __ ]
but [ __ ] bro jake paul that's crazy yeah
and i know what happened with it and i
always say on this podcast allegedly
because
it's not to discredit her it's just i
have to say that because the facts
haven't been proven now
processing yes i'm just
story bro like imagine you get a face
[ __ ] by that guy yeah but he already
got embarrassed by [ __ ] ben askren
with the [ __ ] face shove
oh yeah that was about that dude that
was so
[ __ ] funny dude that was really funny
how good is ben askren at
controlling that [ __ ] dude yeah so good
he's a better troll than than jake paul
yeah sure i'm just so good at it and
he's like he does it in his own ben
askren way
yeah remember he was [ __ ] on a dill
and danish he just kept [ __ ]
just like on instagram he just kept
making these stupid like little
one-liner jokes and then boom roasted
like yeah
yeah he did that like all day and this
floor had nothing to say because he's a
[ __ ]
i 100 believe now because i saw footage
of him boxing
it was a week ago yeah right without ben
askren or jake paul
ben asked him about asking with uh that
guy
julian rosado yeah yeah yeah yeah who's
a legit boxer
he is faking it so bad right now
do you think he is ben askren is hamming
it up really bad dude that's amazing
because his his boxing is getting worse
and worse in all these training videos
he's hamming it up so bad right now
really like he's lit i saw
one recently where it's him hitting pad
works because he's trying to learn how
to do a leaping hook
and it's just so really tom foolery
clowny
i'm like yo oh i gotta see it but bet
astra's face is serious i'm like
your yeah he's literally [ __ ] around
right now
so i hope he can get this w bro i think
he can
i think he will because you think so
yeah because
you think about it right like jake paul
has only fought
three rounds of boxing in his life maybe
three or four
and he he's objectively pretty good like
from amateur standpoint for someone
that's been starting for as long as he
has he's pretty good
right but the level of competition is
not even
at an amateur level like if you go to
like a regular boxing tournament
you'll get guys way better than the
people that he's fighting
so for him to fight the youtuber then
nate robinson
and then fight ben askren that's like a
thousand percent jump in
in competition right like ben askren has
fought and
he's fought he's fought many killers
like in his day and he's
douglas lima he was undefeated for like
10 years and that's mma granted right
but with all those fights comes him
training
sparring with so many different people
and this guy is a decorated athlete and
when it comes with that
that type of athlete you have a certain
type of grit you have a certain type of
mentality
to get him to where he's at and i feel
like jake paul is going to find out what
that's like to fight someone
that has all those intangibles that yeah
skill wise
if you look at ben askren do boxing
you're like yeah he's probably not that
good
but when you fight somebody whether it's
boxing mma or whatever there's so much
more that comes into play
than just practical skills right yeah
yeah so much more comes with
all the intangibles and i feel like ben
askren is gonna get hit
by like jake paul and he's probably
gonna be like oh that's it
cool yeah and he's gonna be fine and i
feel like he's gonna like wear him down
weather the storm and
i mean ben aspen has only been knocked
out once in his whole career
by the craziest knee ever by a flash
knee yeah other than that
no brain trauma at all nope so i think
he's pretty [ __ ] good yeah i think it
just depends on how much to
the i you're right i agree with you on
all the intangibles but just like how
how much like
because if the the the ref if the ref's
cool with a little dirty boxing then
been
asking all day 100 but if it's one of
those refs that like as soon as they
touch he's like break
break you know what i mean it doesn't
let ben askren do anything then i could
see
jake paul like running from him and like
trying to you know
but but what happens once if if ben
askren is
i think you feel like he's likely to
survive the first two three rounds
what happens then it's a 10-round fight
you know like and i'm sure jake
oh they're going 10 rounds yeah i think
jake paul is probably going to be in
really good shape
but it's like it's the different
experience yeah the adrenaline dump like
learning how to deal with that
like learning how to conserve your
energy for a 10 round fight if you're
not doing
that consistently and i don't i'm sure
he he's doing all the things he needs to
because he has really good coaches in
his corner and stuff like that
but having coaches in your corner and
then your ability to actually
execute the game plan on a very big
stage
is two completely different things and
he went into two fights knowing that he
was going to win
yeah right he he knew it yeah yeah i
think he i think he's
thinks he's going to smash manasser like
why wouldn't he right
well he chose somebody who has passed
this prime yeah he's uh
a specialized fighter in wrestling so
right he's thinking that it's going to
be a walk which is a genius move
right like for ben for jake paul to
angle
to get this ben asking fight of all
people is a genius move on his part
because it's the lowest risk highest
reward
oh i beat up uh i'm an olympian yeah
olympia yeah right
you know one fc champion fighter and
bellator fighter
champion like i beat that guy who's next
you know and you can't really deny him
if he beats him at that point i mean
because he could have fought bisping
yeah he could have fought a bunch of
people a lot of people i would have
loved to have seen him fight
missing one eye knocks him out dude oh
yeah easy he's better he knows better
yeah bitching kills him you know 100
percent his management content in
bisping and this thing is like yup let's
do it
easy it was fast yeah because i don't
have to think twice like
uh you don't have a counter at all 40
year old bisping will
[ __ ] destroy him dude yeah [ __ ] yeah
mike perry would be [ __ ] destroyed
jake
oh my god actually maybe we'll see but
like for the most part it's like
you know amanda nunez what a [ __ ] that
when dana white said that it's like i'm
thinking about letting amanda nunes
because i was like amanda nunez will
destroy that
yeah bro because the thing about jake
paul it's like it's always easy when
you're beating
up somebody it's always easy you know
what i mean of course
i put i put david in the ring with
[ __ ] both of the guys jake paul
fought you would ko him easy hey let's
not say that
yeah people start [ __ ] calling me out
and [ __ ] i'm like oh
hold on a second but like you know it's
it's easy when you're the [ __ ] hammer
and you're smashing everybody out but
like
right we'll see what he's made out of if
he experienced some adversity which i
feel like he will
and that's that's the true test right
because anybody can be a woman it's
always weird too because i feel like now
now that people are so good at promoting
themselves
i think a lot of young people are also
kind of taking that
um tactic of of talking themselves up
without having the actual skills dealing
dennis
we were talking about dylan danis you
know and now it's becoming so easy for
people to talk that [ __ ]
but the thing in martial arts you could
talk as much as you want you're going to
find out sooner or later
you know and so like a lot of the times
too even when i started going to
back to sacramento or i went somewhere
else we would go to gyms or whatever and
people wanted the light spar
people talk up a big game and it's like
you're not that good surprisingly for
somebody who's been doing this for this
long
yeah i mean there are people who are
about it but you don't you'll you'll
always love sparring somebody who's
a lot better because they're a lot nicer
to you they they know your skill level
they're not going to just start swinging
at you right exactly
and they never talk about their
accolades they don't say anything
they're just like oh let's just do light
work and they're very nice to you
yeah which i appreciate you know and
it's real easy after you have a sparring
session like that with a guy that's like
really good
and then you know you're not as good as
that person you spar with them and
afterwards you're like hey i did pretty
good bro
you don't know you don't know that that
guy was like oh i'm just gonna go super
easy
but in your head you're like yeah bro
like i was hanging with them dog
like [ __ ] you like touched them and
they're like good job as you're like
hitting them you're like
he's playing with you you're like i'm
pretty much george saint pierre like i'm
the greatest
like and i go tell the story i was like
dude i [ __ ] was piecing up george
saying
it was pretty foreign he was like
fantastic
he's like you know my friend lorraine
yeah you don't know right you know who
uh james charles is
yeah yeah i know james charles he got
he's the makeup guy
yeah well he's also in trouble because
he was sexting a bunch of miners yeah i
heard about that
dude let's look up this guy's who is
this guy and what the [ __ ] he's a makeup
artist and he was sexy
bro let's be real here he's the makeup
guy all right
so social [ __ ] respect oh my bad
so there's this dude right here that guy
he's worth 22 million dollars dude
sexting bull girl boys
damn bro you're james charles bro you're
the hottest [ __ ]
you know dude on the planet i thought
you were talking to me right now i was
like how [ __ ] dare you you james
charles bro you're the hottest guy ever
why do you want to [ __ ] little boys
bro it's so weird it's not
why are you it's like a little boy it's
like a fetish weird fetish thing bro
i gotta read his [ __ ] there's like
screen caps of his conversation because
this is like this
he's always getting in trouble right
about that adreno chrome baby he's
trying to get that adrenaline gonna get
the adrenal chronic
sucking up that balls
but that's [ __ ] i heard he didn't get in
trouble for like
scamming a bunch of people for like
makeup stuff and like stealing people's
ideas i don't know
joker he looks like the joker in that
picture
oh my god let's see he's texting boys
he's sexy
how old are these boys underage
apparently he's like 16 15.
bro why do you want to [ __ ] with little
fifties
little boys dogs
[Music]
but you have to think about how stupid
it is because you're texting people
like yeah information is written it's
there it's like don't you learn from
anybody else dog
like you're there's proof have you seen
catch the predator
you know what i mean yeah like you get
these guys get popped like this is a
thing
yeah look at this bro don't you feel a
little like uneasy or do you feel like
these guys like
the james charles of the world because
he's a very powerful yeah i think that's
part of it you think
they just like yeah nobody will [ __ ]
know yeah i think like the jake paul
[ __ ] like yeah
if that's true you know it's like who
the [ __ ] no yeah it's just weird like
he's thinking
with these like 15 15 14 year old boys
and i'm like
my mind i'm trying to figure out i mean
i i can't get into the head of somebody
who does that for somebody who is under
age
but i do want to understand how he's
somebody who's supposed to be socially
and tech savvy and he has things
written down yeah what the [ __ ] did you
think was going to happen
yeah yeah right they got parents bro
yeah like
if they're 15 or 16 and their parents
see their [ __ ] phone and they see you
[ __ ] chatting up with you know
james charles of all people this guy
with like 15 million
[ __ ] uh instagram followers like i'm
not gonna raise an eyebrow
here's the weird thing too right because
we had this conversation about this this
younger
generation x yeah that talks about how
old hollywood is so
[ __ ] up how old hollywood you you're
never going to get away with the [ __ ]
anymore
new hollywood which is youtube is
exactly the [ __ ] scene
because it's power right yeah it has
nothing to do with
with like hollywood or that in general
it has everything to do with the power
dynamics yeah
if you can get away with it you're gonna
[ __ ] do it yeah yeah yeah you always
gotta fight that inner demon all the
time you gotta fight that monologue
but that's the thing is like not
everyone like it to the
[ __ ] little boys thing not everyone's
gonna do that you know just
it's it's just so crazy like you know
like the only reason i'm not [ __ ]
little boys because you know someone
might catch me
and then james charles was like yo if
they come out and they snitch on me i'll
just get them killed like kevin spacey
my guy like
we're all here baby kevin spacey but
he's like trying to they're
it's these people who feel like they
could just abuse their power all
the [ __ ] time because like what else
is there to do for him right touch my
feet again you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
yeah touch his flat ass feet dude
about flat ass the [ __ ] flappers dude
oh your feet so flat i don't know bro
you got them [ __ ]
hooked on phonics feet down phonics
these oceans bro head kicks for days hey
these oceans
yeah you know so like no yeah
thank you james charles out there stop
hitting up those 16 year old boy
damn bro just go 18. just wait till
they're legal
he's young too he's like something
mm-hmm bro
22 million dollars 22 million power
struggle dude but you're talking about
that
david dabrick dobrik doe brick don't
break dude so we talked
we talked about what happened with that
what happened with that um
another scumbag yeah another [ __ ]
scumbag these guys
well it's like i guess their whole his
whole brand is like
him having these vlogs and like their
lifestyle like each vlog that they do is
like oh today we're going to make this
guy kiss this girl
and what you guys don't know is that
this girl is really going to be a guy
you know it's like [ __ ] it's a murderer
kill somebody yeah today we're going to
kill your mom dude it's a prank okay
they do [ __ ] like that
but apparently like uh one of the guys
in their crew
his name is like dom or something known
as dirty dom because this guy
oh shout outs to dirty dogs
gonna have sex with anybody you know
what i mean yeah and like that's like
his shtick i guess
right so then i guess that's a stick
great stick i'll [ __ ] anything
i'm the quirky gear that have sex with
anybody nerdy now and uh so i
i guess on his instagram he was like yo
i'm trying to have a five some or some
[ __ ]
dirty dumb say dirty dom saying okay
he's like hit me up you down a party
tonight and i guess some girls hit him
up and was like yo
i'm down and kicking with you but not
trying to [ __ ]
me my homegirls are down to kick you
with you like let's link up
so i guess they have a party at some
dude's house or david dobrik's house or
[ __ ] they're all up in there there's
like a bunch of dudes and they show like
clips from the vlog
this is from what i saw oh they
documented this yeah
so that's a thing right it's all on a
vlog and then
these like seven girls come in and i
guess they all made it very clear that
they're not trying to have sex whatever
but they kept trying to like push it on
them and [ __ ] make them drink a
little bit
and they kept feeding or alcohol to like
a couple of these girls
and then sure enough you see them being
really drunk and then he takes
one of the guys takes two of the girls
to like the room
and then in the in the video that the
vlog the show it just sounds like oh
it's like a bunch of dudes like oh man
we're
oh arena it sounds like they're [ __ ]
in there bro like they're [ __ ] for
sure like yeah you know they're doing
that type of [ __ ]
like a very bro-y like frat boy boy type
of [ __ ] kind of like really gross
and then you find out that the girl
comes out saying that
who was involved in the threesome one of
them was passed out apparently
so she wakes up to this dude [ __ ] him
or like she's kind of like not really
there
and then her friend went with him and
was like yo
i'm gonna apparently she like finished
the dude off so he would stop [ __ ]
her
over and then they left and then i think
it took her a little bit to realize that
like oh [ __ ] like
i got taken advantage of i got like
raped like i got kind of like coerced
into
having like over consuming some alcohol
or whatever and they were underage
to drink alcohol as well and then they
show a clip of them going back in the
car and like
actually no so right after the sex like
this dude is like it's it was weird this
fools weren't a sweatband because he
just [ __ ] or whatever
[ __ ] what the hell is going on with
this yeah he just like
from the video clips i saw i was like
this guy doesn't look very likeable
yeah yeah clearly apparently yeah
apparently he has some other [ __ ] on him
or whatever you know so
whatever uh he's all sweaty he's like
yeah dude at my first threesome they're
like dude smell my fingers they're doing
[ __ ] like this and then to me
my whole view of david dobrik was like
oh i thought he was like a wholesome
guy yeah so i didn't know he was doing
this type of [ __ ] so i was like oh this
is kind of crazy
and then they get in their car and
they're filming in the car and they're
like yo we're
gonna go like they're making a joke
saying like oh [ __ ] we're gonna go to
jail like this is crazy yada yada
so which is kind of a weird thing to say
yeah
i think he raped guys oh [ __ ]
there's a group of guys that like kind
of coercing all this and they're like oh
[ __ ] you know we're
going to go to jail like haha like
joking joking
and then one of my clients who's a
really big fan like she's she's a big
fan of david dobrik whatever she was the
one like telling me all this stuff and
she was giving me more backstory about
all this other stuff and how he kind of
coordinates
like all these vlogs and how he
is the mastermind behind all this stuff
and it's to him it's content at the end
of the day right it's like oh we made
dom
ever threesome what a cool thumbnail and
a cool title how the [ __ ] is that you
have spot
because i only know about uh david
dobrik because
um he did this article about how his
whole channel got demonetized right
and so he has he makes more money now
because he just has sponsors
yeah how the [ __ ] do these major brands
sponsor him
but then my channel is look like it's a
piece of [ __ ] this guy literally has
videos of like where a guy has a
threesome and then you have [ __ ]
johnson
johnson
sponsors this guy yeah and i'm the
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you companies but continue yeah
[ __ ] you man so and then
so and then like she was telling me some
other [ __ ] i just hit myself in the face
with the [ __ ] mic
uh she she was telling me some other
stuff uh shout out my girl asia you know
and she was saying like she showed me a
clip on a podcast he was talking to this
guy named
jason nash or some [ __ ] he's like this
older dude apparently he's a jewish guy
and then this jewish dude is talking
about like how he was growing up and
all these uh kids would make fun of them
for being jewish
so they would like at school they would
like throw pennies at them and [ __ ] and
be like haha
like [ __ ] jew like they would like do
that type of [ __ ] whatever god
damn [ __ ] up right like super [ __ ]
up like god damn this is that there's
another black kid we should throw
chicken bones in his face
what the [ __ ] so and then his the kid
david dobrik is talking to him about
this this guy jason is sharing his uh
his experience of him being picked on
for being jewish growing up
and then this dude uh david dobrik is
like yeah that's like pretty cool though
like that was like what they did at our
high school like our teachers would join
in like it was like a thing your
teachers would join in
they would check the adults would throw
pennies at them too
like bills but he was saying like oh
yeah like our school
like we would make fun of jews like all
the time like it was like a thing like
oh yeah that's not that bad like that's
his response to what his story was about
him like
opening up about how he was getting
picked on all the time being racially
abused and he's like
he's like that's cool bro like what we
did was this
and like kind of goes on the story of
the jews
is he older like in his 30s or something
who david dobrik i think he's a younger
dude he sounds like he's the younger
dude well i saw picked him he looks kind
of old
why'd you say he does wholesome family
[ __ ] that's what i what
i assume because he does vlogs and he
gets uh sponsored by all these major
artists when you do that type of [ __ ]
you don't get your answer by [ __ ]
brawny and [ __ ]
brawny dude hey jews get brony
this old looking [ __ ] is 24 years old is
he 24
he's 24. this was hella wrinkles on his
face already what the [ __ ] is probably
from all the raping dude that's probably
yeah cuz like because all these people
that i know that watch his stuff
are quite wholesome people i was like oh
you you know you watch this [ __ ] you're
into it
and they're like oh yeah he's such a
good dude he gives cars to people so
that's like all the stuff i heard this
guy's weird this whole
this whole world of [ __ ] is so weird
it's such odd
[ __ ] so odd you know god looks like a
creepy [ __ ] dude
it's like a dirty dog clown type in
dirty dom
that dude he's like you whatever you
picture him
is exactly what he looks like he's 24
years old i like how this guy opens up
about him getting racially abused he
goes nah man you tripping dude
like you tripping oh yeah like they did
that [ __ ] todd like yeah
like it was okay what the [ __ ] are you
talking about guys like you're openly
admitting to be anti-semitic yeah all
good my baby
all good baby the guy kind of didn't
know how to react he was like uh
dirty dumb right here yeah look at this
[ __ ] guy bro okay
that's crazy he looks like rick moranis
it looks crazy as [ __ ] too
what's up someone see these dudes just
piecing their asses up bro bro like just
piece them up real quick these dudes are
very punchy these fools look
like they did definitely look older i
feel like they might be older dudes
acting like they they have to be dude
because this is weird
they just doing hey you're white and
you're wearing a do-rag bro what are you
doing
what do you say come on and of all
people this [ __ ] guy you hear this
guy talking
he has a dare shirt instead of dare it
says clouds oh
which i'm assuming has to do with vaping
or sorry
or like smoking jewels yeah bro oh my
god there's a [ __ ]
clown bro i hope he gets in trouble
dirty this guy
i i really i do not understand how you
could put that
like at all choose to wear that clothes
like
okay as a joke you want to be funny as a
skit whatever boom but if you seriously
are going to wear some [ __ ] like that
and then you you
think like i'm going to go out in public
and then take a picture and then
you're cool i don't understand the
psychology yeah dog
i really don't understand you have seven
holes in your jeans there's so many
words like there's so many
like red like alerts that go hey don't
do this dog he's wearing a do-rag that
says
dirty dom and also it's not spelled how
do you spell it
it's spelled on his do-rag it's not
spelled correctly
on his do ragged spell d-u-r-t-e i
believe that's dirty
and also don't be cute with it bro i'd
love to see this dude just walk up with
it to a bunch of like black folk and
just have that do-rag on
oh my gosh bro [ __ ] out he has to be in
his late 30s dude he looks old that's
all the [ __ ] there's
no way these guys are in there i think
they i feel like they're older acting
young because they look older
these guys make a bunch of [ __ ] cucks
you know maybe dobrick or whatever the
[ __ ]
look at this guy this guy does not look
like he's 24. no yeah he doesn't
and he's dude's posting pictures of him
flexing like creatine castle baby
get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
i heard i heard david dobrik got some
trouble for like making
one of these one of his homies like kiss
some
some chick oh my god who was supposed to
be associated like some like
some pretty chick or whatever and then
it turned out to be
another like an older dude in a wig and
was like yo
i made you kiss
and this is what major companies sponsor
are you out of your
mind i don't want to hear youtube talk
about clean content and sponsorship
ever again dude yeah this guy racked in
15
million last year and he's on
sponsorship he's like the biggest
like youtuber right like he's the
youtube guy blows my [ __ ] mind dude
he's the casey
neistat of this generation apparently
right like that's who
that's everyone that i hear talk about
how big youtube is they always bring up
david dobrik
that's [ __ ] crazy dude this blows my
mind
oh no [ __ ] though this guy's like
creating content of a guy just raping a
girl and then the world's just like
oh it's all right i'm johnson and
johnson johnson and john this
this video was brought to you by johnson
and johnson yeah powder your ass
yeah it's crazy that is the craziest
thing i've ever heard in my [ __ ] life
man i can't i don't understand the video
that they showed too that they showed us
apparently was like it was all the clips
from the actual vlog that is taken down
but it was all the clips leading up to
the whole incident
and like when you watch it like you feel
kind of gross afterwards for sure
like you just felt like oh man what the
[ __ ] that i watch
uh because it kind of took me a little
bit to process it too because after we
watched it i was like huh it's [ __ ]
kind of weird but this is like the
standard of content now like you have to
do
crazier and crazier things when you
create these [ __ ]
social idiots they think that it's okay
and then all of a sudden
they get snapped out of it when they're
like hold on a second this isn't normal
like they have a bunch of yes men around
them they look at view counts and this
is how they see
this is what their moral barometer is
and that's how they look at people right
it's like
oh you gave me good views come on let's
do this video you [ __ ] well that's
how it is too like even in this
city too like some of these kids they
they kind of develop relationships based
on what they can achieve like get from
somebody yeah
which i get if it's a business
transaction but like i even heard
friends where they
they they'll hang out with it's supposed
to be like a hangout and they go well
like i'm trying to i'm trying to like
get my social networking on it's like
yeah we're supposed to be friends bro
the [ __ ] are you talking about yeah yeah
that's so weird hey let's go and then
hey are you interested in buying some
monavie products of course i made 10 000
last month yeah i never understood that
because it is like networking is big in
entertainment but it's like
there's people that go out there with
just the intent to network and i've
never
i could just never i just felt gross to
me like if we get along we get along
cool that i'm great i want
i'm down to be the homie but like for re
like the connection's gonna be
legit it can't be like i'm just here to
like milk you for some [ __ ] that's weird
as [ __ ]
it's so phony and like like gross well
that's why some
a lot of people too when they come here
they they have this idea of what los
angeles is right so they'll go out and
they'll create these
fictitious friendships or whatever based
on what they can gain from somebody
yeah right and then after they start to
realize they go well
everybody's fake in la blah blah blah
blah because like nobody's like a real
homie it's like
what are you talking you're the fake one
too though you developed the french
based on what you can get out of this
person yeah right so you got butt hurt
because you thought
it's basically like this it's like you
guys were [ __ ] buddies and then you
assumed it was a relationship
so you're the dumbass you know i mean
it's not people in l.a it's you're the
people in l.a
you're the one that's developing these
fake friendships because of what you can
gain from somebody
like like this guy david dabrick and his
friends right like is
all this [ __ ] goes down david dobrik or
dabrick doesn't make any [ __ ] money
at all
would they still be friends what are
their conversations like aside from hey
what's our next video
yeah right next big thing that we're
going to do yeah right what is their
conversations like
you know none of these kids too i don't
say none but a lot of these people that
i'm meeting here they don't have
a lot of good and long-lasting
friendships there hasn't been a
good balance and medium for these kids
to figure out like okay how do i
like socialize with regular people how
do i develop real relationships
and then what do i keep for business
they think that it's all same it's not
you have your friends you have your
homies and you have your acquaintances
not everybody's supposed to be your
[ __ ] friend here
yeah that's true that's why we should do
more prank videos together you guys down
bro yeah you guys you guys go to
supermarkets and start shoving people
and be like yo it's a prank
no i wasn't praying i'm doing japanese
prank videos oh
yeah i'm setting somebody up in a
[ __ ] cabin they're going to sit down
a chair it's going to open the back yeah
flip out and just shoot them down
i was like i got you those are the best
dude
i love those [ __ ] did you guys watch
that bad trip movie on netflix no
that's just funny dude watch it it's
good and that's all i'll say okay let's
watch it
it's weird i'm a big eric andre fan yeah
this is just my bread of butter tiffany
always makes a joke about when people
come to my house
i hold them hostage but i just show them
eric andre stuff okay
that's my thing so our magruber magruber
and like eric andre
but um when just watch a bad trip i'm
just curious to see what you think
it's pretty it's pretty cool or not
pretty cool don't you make a choice yeah
if
you like it or not i don't know i don't
know it's up to you guys whether you
think it's good or not
because i don't because usually when i
go and be like yo it's so [ __ ] good
everyone's like you don't want to build
expectations i'm not going to build no
expectations
it's not japanese prank level i don't
[ __ ] japanese pranks shows were the
best
care how do you prank somebody by having
an elevator collapse
how is that okay yeah or the grudge one
remember they used to be like
like the lights would go out and then
there's an elevator right now they'd be
like [ __ ]
yeah they did one where they set up an
actor or an actress and they're in their
makeup room
and the light starts flickering and then
it's a double-sided mirror and there's
like a grudge character behind oh my god
that's so funny
it's so and then out of nowhere just
bust through the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and they start chasing them around
they're terrified to death of course
yeah what the [ __ ] sounds so cute that's
hilarious there's a deleted scene from
the eric andre the bad trip movie right
and it has to do with this holiday yeah
i wasn't even listening to what you just
said
that's better okay no no it's not better
but it's still pretty funny because it
just reminds me the same type of bit so
like they did like exorcism break and
they're like the deep south and
they're at a hotel and eric andre's in a
bed and he's like he's like feeling
really sick and they ask this lady to
come take care of him she's like a nurse
and then in the room they just start
like [ __ ] with the room
so like they'll have like blood come
down the wall like just like a little
bit
and then but it's like very faint enough
where she's like what the [ __ ] is that
and then the lights start flickering
and then she sits down and then there's
a picture frame it's like a double
it's a i guess what's a one-way mirror i
guess and it flickers and there's like
this [ __ ]
you know like like a ghost in there and
lady like freaks out she runs out and
they bring a priest in
and like they do and like he's like yo
i've done so many exorcisms like i know
how to deal with this [ __ ]
so they faked the exorcism and he's like
freaking out he's like coughing up blood
or whatever the [ __ ] he's like
and he's doing his whole thing like the
power of christ compels you and he's
like freaking out and the guy is like
kind of freaking out because there's
blood coming down the walls like the
lights are flickering tv's going on and
off
and then he's asking the dude lil rel i
guess
his co-star he's like yo film this for
me real quick he's like the power of
christ compels you he's like doing all
these bits and i explained that terribly
so just watch the video clip
but it's good it's really good what the
[ __ ] was that
yo as i was explaining it i was like
okay i forgot about this
forgot about that i'm sorry i stressed
you out you wasted five minutes of my
life on a story that had no ending
we out here baby thank you i'm just
looking upon just watching on youtube
that's all i should have said i don't
know who was getting pranked or who eric
andre was in the whole thing
that made no sense i'm just gonna crack
this open and [ __ ] drink it until i
die
what the [ __ ] was that so
what happened did you have a seizure
yeah so why did you everything i said
about david dobrik
probably not true i hate it so you pull
the frog
what made you think it was a good idea
to say that you know what
let me tell you let me tell you
once you stop laughing uncontrollably
let me tell you
oh [ __ ] okay you want to know how i have
adult adv
the reason why the only reason why i
brought this up
sweating bro the only reason why i
brought this up
don't give me a paper towel bro don't
just sit there
why are you wearing a sweater bro it's
[ __ ] 90 degrees in here
oh it's funny hard to do
now i'm sweating more and that's a
problem dude
[Laughter]
yeah this was the hugest was on trial
right now oh
[ __ ] that feeling that he felt that's
what bombing feels like that's what it
feels like
and i'm used to it baby hey this is
exactly what it feels like that's why
i saw this camera i think i just had it
your head was shimmery dude
i think i just had my first stand-up set
bro oh that really is
so going back to my point the only
reason i brought that up was because
there it was just two ghost stories and
i was like oh yeah that's related and i
just
i just went into it that is exactly what
it's like to bomb a set
yeah guys
i know exactly how this dude feels right
now i'm sweating man [ __ ] you that was a
lot of sweat that was a lot of that
right there
is exactly what foreign that's how jake
paul's going to be
when he [ __ ] fights oh man that [ __ ]
was that was hilarious dude
yeah i'm not even sweating i'm actually
glad he told my story now
you saw how cool i played that man i
played that so cool yeah
damn dude luke
bro i've never seen somebody bail out on
a story so hard in my life dude
yeah you know and i just was like you
know what that's why you should go watch
it yourself
and i was like you know what i'll accept
the consequences of this one you sold it
well
thank you that was the worst dude that
was worth
it don't you ever criticize funny shots
he's like almost on the edge of my seat
i really was i was waiting for something
i was waiting too because you know and
as i was explaining i was like
yeah it's one of those things you just
got to watch it and that's that's my mo
baby that's my thing yeah but you could
have came to that conclusion like three
minutes earlier than that dude
yeah you know yeah yeah and you know i
saved because i was like oh i'm gonna go
to the next thing
and then i was like as i was talking i
was like no did you guys did you guys
did i tell you guys about the uh
the japanese porno prank no no what's
that uh
it was this is yeah good luck explaining
this one huh
this is one of the worst and funniest
pranks i've ever seen on my life it was
on e-fucked
oh he [ __ ] it's crazy bad there are
two japanese porn stars about to do like
a gang bang scene right what's up with
all that bro
hey man it's whatever you know ohayo
gozaimasu
and so one of the girls mid scene stops
and she goes oh i have to go to the
trailer i forgot something
so she goes into the trailer the trailer
explodes
so it explodes and so that's like that
girl's best friend
he's like oh my god what happened and
the director's like shocked and comes
over to he goes
they'll have to continue the scene so
this girl's balling crying sucking dick
i'm not getting [ __ ] oh my god she's
crying and she's getting [ __ ]
it like [ __ ]
alive just kidding yo
and she's like i can't believe you did
that she takes the [ __ ] and then she
throws it on her friend's face
is she laughing she's crying cause she
thought her best friend just died and it
exploded
because she's like now i have to do the
scene all by myself that's
next level [ __ ] that's the most [ __ ]
up [ __ ] i've ever heard in my life
that's what i'm saying that's pretty
more videos
it
to blow up a trailer holy [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying if it's not
japanese level [ __ ] around i want to see
him
bro the japanese are good at everything
they do go to prison they're so good at
everything like that so
they put their mind to it becomes the
best because the one where they had this
girl like this dude or a girl [ __ ]
sleeping in a cabin and in the middle of
the sleep
they hooked the bungee cords to it and
shot her through the [ __ ] foot
bro what the [ __ ] what happened to her
they strapped her down while he was it
was he or she but they strapped him out
of the bed so they woke up
why through the [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
hilarious
oh my god that's so crazy dude there's
that [ __ ] so that's like next level mind
torture
[ __ ] [ __ ] like the porn one oh my god
that's dangerous the bungee jump one
that sounds [ __ ] hilarious dude
there's another one too this is my
favorite one i shared this with tim too
there's a guy who's like a comedian he's
like a japanese comedian or entertainer
right
but they pranked this dude for like a
whole [ __ ] year
like a whole year a whole year and they
wouldn't tell him when they were going
to prank him and they would do it by
by dumping him in boiling water oh my
god
boiling water
this guy is third degree burns again so
they're like shooting stuff with him
right or whatever but they're pranking
him throughout like a month like month
two months or like a year
and so he's just walking down the the
hallway and they remove the tiles
where the tiles are just loose pieces of
paper and it's just hot water inside
[ __ ] he's like oh [ __ ] he's crawling out
of this hot water
and then they roll in a [ __ ] bucket
of ice and he just gets in there and
they go
you got pranks and then like a month
later
he's like he's like a variety show
comedian he's like dressed up in his
little variety show comic outfit
he goes into a van and he's like super
cautious but he goes into this van
the [ __ ] van back seat flips
backwards
again
dude bro the boy water robbie's
the third one is the worst so he's he's
my man got ptsd
an award show he can't trust him he's in
a tuxedo
he's dressed up for this he's about to
receive an award
and he just
[Laughter]
these people are [ __ ] up i don't
imagine that happening at the oscars and
was like yo
we had to do that to ryan gosling
because you know we have this prank
going on they just keep
[ __ ] this guy up man oh my god
japanese people are
nuts that's so funny they are the king
of pranks though dude i want to play
silent library yeah that [ __ ] is so
funny it's inherently funny
that we did that on jk news that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] hilarious
i want to do it remember they did it
with ernesto hoost
yeah yeah they did that oh that was
ernesto who's the
big buff black dude yeah i was like
who's this random black dude in these
videos
and he's so funny he speaks japanese
then i guess
i guess or you could play that game
without you know speaking english
because they can't really talk
they would do something so if you
laughed you were out then huh if you
like raised a bullet above a certain
like decibel they like punished you or
you laughed
i think no because if you got the the
skull card someone like paddled your ass
or did some crazy [ __ ]
dude there's one so this is one of the
funniest videos i've ever seen and until
this day it still makes me cry laughing
they just have this guy he's like a
comic but he has a bowl cut
and he's supposed to read an english yes
bro he's reading the [ __ ] uh like
he goes on 100 he's cute yeah oh yeah
they make these guys sit in the class
and they can't laugh
yeah and it's so funny they get paddled
in the ass like
full [ __ ] force like it's not even a
slight smack it's a full force
ass whooping dude they made it some
english and the english they're making
read was so [ __ ] hard i know it was
like
it had like it was talking like
christopher columbus or some [ __ ] he
said
it was like a simple word but he's this
whole started going into french and [ __ ]
he was most of
your lotions
he goes he was a question and that [ __ ]
got somebody so bad dude yeah
and then they bend over and they get
slapped with a [ __ ] kendo stick
dude it's so funny so that was the one i
saw with i don't know if he pulled the
the skull card or it was like they were
trying to make [ __ ] laugh
but what something whatever happened
this old dude comes out and like
like gets themselves oh when he sucks in
his ear takes his teeth out
so like like it's like they just see
this they're all kind of looking at him
right now
it's just some like little innocent
looking old dude they're kind of like
all right but there's a little like
some [ __ ] up shit's gonna happen
because that's the nature of this show
dude pulls his teeth out
and it starts like sucking and nibbling
on his ear and the guy's like ah
and they're all like can you let go and
the guy like
they're holding him because he's like
freaking the [ __ ] out he's like he's
gonna run away
and they're like no no you gotta stay
that's the worst thing i've ever heard
in my
life like some old dude nibbling over
they had whatever they had to like eat
like wasabi
uh like just pure wasabi and like a
seaweed oh they did the uh the [ __ ]
nose hair pulling dude yeah
that was so bad that hurts so much man
that show so remember do you guys
remember mxc
yeah i used to love that show too it was
mxc you never seen that one uh
so it's like a it's an old japanese game
show where they have like people it's
like a wipeout
but like to the next degree and i think
it was like from the 90s or something
yeah and
yeah and like they were doing the most
outlandish [ __ ] and then
uh i guess spike tv bought the rights to
it
and they would dub over it in english
with like silly goofy [ __ ] they weren't
saying the things that they were saying
and they were making like silly ass
teams like it was just a bunch of like
the meat packers versus like the fairies
or something
yeah they were like but then the
wipeouts of what happened on this show
yeah quite drastic these people had no
business doing this [ __ ] obstacle
courses
and all those obstacle courses are meant
for you to get
[ __ ] up on like terrible yeah and it's
just a compilation of people just
getting [ __ ] up like you would have to
run up this alley
and there's all these boulders yeah
giant boulders coming down at you and
they're obviously like paper mache but
like if you get hit by one of those
[ __ ]
you're flying yeah like you're getting
[ __ ] up that's hilarious they had
these crooks
where you could sneak in and not get hit
by the the boulders and then you'd come
back out and time it and you have to
zigzag
but then some of them there's people
inside of them that are dressed up like
rocks and we'll like push you back out
oh [ __ ] and they're like fighting with
them
you'd be like please please please and
then fly down
did you see the one where there's these
two guys have to karaoke why two girls
are sucking their dick
no no what bro what yeah like you're
talking about this like
this is on jeopardy or they have
something
karaoke while two girls are sucking
their dick and they have to finish the
song wow
so then they're singing that's amazing
dude that's incredible
that you [ __ ] two was that i think it
was effective
[Laughter]
bro three podcasts ago
that was ten minutes to go bro wow man
it was crazy one of the funniest and
worst experiences of my life
the journey to nowhere you're imagining
how i felt that's what this podcast is
gonna be called the journey to nowhere
[Applause]
i think yeah that's that's pretty bad
that's pretty bad yeah well guys that
wraps up today
of the genius parade podcast we're gonna
put the note of nick bobby hey man don't
have me back bro that's actually been on
this podcast for a solid year
you've never bought them like that
before sometimes and you miss baby
that's my life that's it yeah but you
missed by like seven minutes i missed i
missed i hit i made the wrong basket
that's what i did yeah
but you can find nick crying at his
bathroom
for tonight on my instagram live
[ __ ] yeah you [ __ ] why would you
say that your mom was right about you
when hooked up
oh
and as i was explaining i was like ah
this ain't going anywhere
goodbye nick at fulfilling prophecy
on instagram and you can find patrick
patrick.tv
but it just sucks around us i just have
david
[ __ ] five feet away from me laughing
in my face you're not sweating anymore
so that's how we know that for sure
right
now you're good you're listening there
you're touching me krispy kreme donut
earlier
oh that's not that's not sweat boy
you're good
the kill shot
you guys can catch us every thursday and
sunday not the only silver one is the
thing yeah
everyone else is [ __ ] drinking
perform a sentence we'll see you all
next time